foreign
for you today let's talk about them well
a few episodes ago we talked about the
80 20 rule I wanted to expand on that
because I think it goes well beyond our
time which you often talk about the 80
20 rule with respect to our time how am
I spending my time but the 80 20 rule
applies to almost everything in our
lives 20 of your clothes you wear 80 of
the time that means 20 of your shirts
you wear 80 of the time twenty percent
of your pants you wear 80 of the time
twenty percent of your accessories of
your jewelry of your handbags of your
watches you wear 80 of the time
twenty percent of the things you own is
what you use eighty percent of the time
one might even say that twenty percent
of your friends or who you spend eighty
percent of your time with 20 of the
things that you focus on have eighty
percent of the significance or the
importance in your life it's not that
the other
eighty percent of the things that we
wear the things that we do the friends
in our lives are bad
but sometimes we hold on to
relationships or we certainly hold on to
old clothes old furniture old kitchen
appliances old sheets and towels and and
blankets and
hygiene products accessories that we're
holding on to just in case
we never use those things or we use them
so rarely that they've become cluttered
and so why not appreciate the 20 of the
things that we use more and really
expand on those maybe it could be not
the 80 20 rule but 20 percent of my
things that I own
I get rid of all those other things that
are in the way now all of a sudden I
just use a hundred percent of my things
because that other eighty percent I got
it out of the way that right there is
the power of minimizing man that has
done wonders for me professionally when
I realize that 80 of the value I was
creating was coming from only 20 of the
things I was doing it made me step back
and say well why is that only 20
why am I wasting so much energy and
effort doing things where I am highly
replaceable and then I just started to
focus on those things what are those
things that make me indispensable where
what are those areas where I'm difficult
to replace can I make that 30 can I make
that 50 can I negotiate that upward to
80 and when you do that you're saying no
to meetings you're saying no to things
that you may not be great at and it
looks like you're just saying no but
after a while you start to show up
really really powerfully in those areas
where you're getting the value from and
so it's like you actually get to get
more out of that eighty percent yeah and
it made me also start to question the
other eighty percent why am I clinging
to this other 80 percent just because
it's volume and it's there but I'm not
getting any use out of it and if it
turns out that 20 of my clothes I'm
wearing eighty percent of the time it's
probably also true that those 20 of the
clothes that I wear I could wear a
hundred percent of the time and I could
just let go of everything else that I
don't enjoy as much did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free